O
AND A POWERFUL MESSAGE, THANK YU
FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT.
AND IT'S NOT JUST BLM THAT HAS
BEEN EXPOSED, BUT ALSO THE
MEDIA'S INCESSANT LIES ABOUT THE
VIOLENCE THAT THAT MOVEMENT
SEWED.
RETURNING TO PORTLAND TO
DOCUMENT THEIR CONTINUED
STRUGGLE AGAINST THE VIOLENCE.
WHAT TOOK JUST ONE NIGHT FOR A
SUSPECTED THUG STAGE SO THE NT
FOR NATURE -- DEFINE ANDY AND
SEND THEM TO THE HOSPITAL.
JOINING ME NOW, EDITOR AT LARGE
OF THE POST-MILLENNIAL, AUTHOR
OF "UNMASKED."
HE IS JOINING US FROM A
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION.
HOW ARE THEY ABLE TO FIND YOU
AND ATTACK YOU SO QUICKLY?
>> AS YOU PROBABLY NOTICED ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO I WAS BEATEN BADLY
WHEN I WAS COVERING A PUBLIC
DEMONSTRATION IN DOWNTOWN
PORTLAND.
BUT THAT DIDN'T SILENCE ME, I
CONTINUE TO DO MY REPORTING.
AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME I WAS
ACTUALLY UNDERCOVER FULLY IN
THEIR UNIFORM MARCHING ALONG
WITH THEM.
I THINK WHAT GAVE IT AWAY IT WAS
THEY PAID ATTENTION TO THE FACT
THAT I WASN'T ENGAGING IN THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES WITH THEM
SUCH AS THROWING PROJECTILES AT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR TRYING TO
DAMAGE THE CENTRAL POLICE
STATION.
SO THEY SOME PEOPLE OVER TO
INTERROGATE ME AND THEN THEY
PULLED OFF MY MASK AND MY
GOGGLES AND SHOUTED "THAT'S HIM,
GET HIM, GOT HIM."
AND I WALKED FROM DOWNTOWN
PORTLAND IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STREET -- THERE WAS NO POLICE
BEAR THE FASTEST ONE IN THE MOB
CAUGHT UP TO ME, TACKLED ME, AND
REPEATEDLY PUNCHED ME ON THE
BACK OF MY HEAD AND MY FACE AND
I WAS PLEADING FOR MERCY.
HE GOT DISTRACTED, I GOT UP AND
RAN INTO THE NEAREST THING THAT
WAS OPEN, BECAUSE MOST OF THE
BUSINESSES IN DOWNTOWN PORTLAND
ARE BOARDED UP.
WHEN I GOT IN, I PLED WITH THE
HOTEL SECURITIES AND STAFF TO
CALL 911 AND THEY TOLD ME THAT I
NEEDED TO PUT ON A MASK AND THAT
I HAD TO LEAVE.
>> Laura: OLD, GOD.
I WANT TO SHOW AN IMAGE OF
SOMEONE YOU SAY ASSAULTED YOU --
ALSO REPORTEDLY YELLED THEY WERE
GOING TO BEAT THE [BLEEP] OUT OF
YOU YOU BLEED.
ANOTHER REASON WE DON'T WANT THE
MASK, YOU CAN'T IDENTIFY ANYONE
COMMITTING ACTS OF CRIMINALITY.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE POLICE?
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD BACK FROM A
DETECTIVE AT ALL.
WHICH -- I HAVE MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN REPORTS TO POLICE, DEATH
THREATS, PEOPLE SHOWING UP AT MY
FAMILY'S HOME.
THAT WAS THE REASON WHY I HAD TO
FLEE PORTLAND LAST YEAR AND THE
REASON WHY I CAME BACK WAS TO
CARE FOR MY ELDERLY PARENTS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THEM TO BE ON THE GROUND TO SEE.
>> Laura: IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
ON THE GROUND, BUT APPARENTLY
YOU HAVE A TARGET ON YOUR BACK.
YOU CAN'T JUST KEEP GETTING
BEATEN IN THE HEAD, IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE GOOD FOR YOU.
YOU JUST CAN'T.
SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PICK UP THE MANTLE HERE, BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHO YOU ARE AND
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO KILL
YOU.
THEY WOULD IF THEY COULD